l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 49 de Monsieur Jean-Claude
Carl à monsieur le ministre du Travail
de l'Emploi de la Formation
Professionnelle et du dialogue social la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude Carles
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur la question du financement
des indemnités chômage des travailleurs
frontaliers exerçant en Suisse
aujourd'hui très problématique et
surtout très défavorable à la France du
fait de la substitution du droit
communautaire à certains accords
bilatéraux en cas de chômage total les
frontaliers sont indemnisés par leur
pays de résidence en l'occurrence la
France la convention franco-suisse
d'assurance chômage du 14 décembre 1978
prévoyait une rétrocession d'une partie
des cotisation perçu sur les salaires
des frontaliers au titre de l'assurance
chômage équivalent à 90 % des cotisation
à la suite de l'entrée en application de
l'accord de libre circulation des
personnes et conformément au protocole
de l'annexe 2 de cet accord cette
rétrocession a été maintenue jusqu'au 31
mai 2009 ainsi des derniers chiffres
dont on dispose il apparaît que le
montant de la rétrocession des
cotisations auprès de l'Unedic s'est
élevé à plus de 119 millions d'euros
représentant autant de manque à gagner
pour la France depuis le 1er janvier
2010 conformément à la reprise de
l'acquis communautaire par la Suisse
cette rétrocession n'a plus lieu
d'exister depuis le 1er avril 2012 le
règlement 883 200004 s'applique entre la
Suisse et les États de l'Union
européenne en fonction de ce nouveau
texte les prestations de chômage restent
à la charge de l'institution de l'État
de résidence toutefois l'état d'emploi
rembourse la totalité du montant des
prestations servies pendant les 3
premiers mois de l'indemnisation cette
période peut être étendue à 5 mois sous
conditions de durée minimale de la
dernière activité je dois à ce propos
signaler que le règlement stipule que
les États peuvent prévoir d'autres
méthodes de remboursement notamment en
concluant des accords bilatéraux je
souhaiterais donc savoir Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord si les autorités
françaises sont en mesure de demander le
remboursement aux autorités helvétiques
ce qui se pose d'avoir identifié
parfaitement les les chômeurs
frontaliers et d'autre part à quelle
durée correspond aujourd'hui la
rétrocession est-ce que c'est 3 ou
est-ce que c'est 5 mois enfin le
gouvernement compte-il saisir
l'opportunité offerte par le règlement
et entamer une négociation avec la
Confédération hvétique pour aller
au-delà et ce d'autant plus monsieur le
ministre que dans certains métiers en
tension que vous connaissez bien la
mécanique les infirmières la France
subit si vous me permettez l'expression
la double peine en effet nous formons
les jeunes à ces métiers souvent par la
voie de l'apprentissage et au terme de
leur formation ils sont ass inspiré par
la suite du fait des salaires plus
attractifs mais lorsque le contexte
économique de ce pays décroit et qu'ils
sont le cas échéant licencié c'est le
système d'indemnisation du chômage
français qui les prend en charge la
France donc paye la formation et paye
aussi les indemnités de chômage des
informations que nous avons pu
recueillir il semblerait que la Suisse
ne soit pas opposée à négocier un
dispositif différent moins pénalisant
pour la France enfin je tiens à
souligner que les frontaliers
n'entendent pas être des assistés du
système du régime français alors qu'ils
ont acquitté leur cotisation en Suisse
et qu'ils ne peuvent prétendre à
l'indemnisation du fait de la
législation hvétique pour conclure
monsieur le ministre au moment où le
gouvernement recherche tous les moyens
de et les ressources possibles pour
réduire les déficits publics et
notamment celui de la sécurité sociale
cette mesure me semble plus juste et
plus équitable que celle que vous
apprêteriez selon nos informations à
mettre en œuvre celle-ci vise en effet à
relever de 8 à 13 et5i % le cotisation
d'assurance maladie des frontaliers
affillé à la CMU à compté de janvier
prochain ce qui induirait une perte de
pouvoir d'achat moyenne de 1500 € pour
chacun des 180000 travailleurs
frontaliers français d'autant plus que
selon nos informations vous envigerz
aussi euh d'avancer de mai 2014 au début
2013 l'échéance de fin du droit d'option
permettant à ces actifs de choisir entre
la CMU et l'assurance privée merci mon
cher collègue la parole à Monsieur
Thierry ropentin ministre chargé de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur Carl voilà un sujet
que vous connaissez bien auquel aurait
eu plaisir vous répondre Michel Sapin
ministre de l'Emploi du travail de la
formation professionnelle du dialogue
social s'il n'avait été retenu sur un
autre engagement j'ai donc plaisir à
vous vous confirmer ainsi qu'à vos
collègues que comme vous l'avez dit le
système de rétrocession réciproque des
contributions d'assurance chômage qui
prévalait entre la France et la Suisse a
pris fin le 31 mai 2009 c'est tout à
fait vrai et depuis le 1er mai 2010 il y
a un nouveau règlement du communé
européenne du 29 avril 2004 et des
règlements d'application qui portent sur
la coordination des systèmes de sécurité
sociale qui sont donc entré en vigueur
je vous confirme qu'ils instituent un
nouveau système de ocession basé sur le
remboursement de prestation de chômage
des trois premiers mois d'indemnisation
ce remboursement pouvont être étendus à
5 mois depuis le 1er avril 2012 ces
nouveaux règlements communautaires sont
applicables à la Suisse c'est
relativement récent la France peut donc
demander le remboursement à la Suisse
des allocations chômage correspondant à
des droits ouverts à compter du 1er
avril
2012 pour déterminer le montant devant
donner est lieu à remboursement il est
nécessaire néanmoins d'attendre quelques
mois les premières demandes seront ainsi
adressées en fin d'année 2012 et
concerneront les dossiers des
allocataires ayant un droit ouvert à
compter du 1er avril 2012 et un dernier
jour indemnisé au cours de la période de
remboursement de 3 ou 5 mois soit au
plus tard le 30 juin 2012 en effet pour
demander le remboursement des
allocations versées pourô emploi dispose
d'un délai de 6 mois suivant la fin du
semestre civil au cours duquel a été
effectué le dernier paiement des
prestations chômage si l'on se réfère
donc à la masse de prestation versée en
2011 correspondant à 3 mois
d'indemnisation la France aurait pu
exiger un remboursement de 40 millions
d'euros au minimum au titre de l'année
2011 sur la base d'environ 4500
allocataires
indemnisé en assurance chômage mais plus
généralement je souhaite vous dire que
les demandes de remboursement pour les
États de l'Union européenne ont été mis
en place à compté de la date d'entrée en
vigueur des nouveaux règlements
communautaires soit à compté du 1er mai
2010 or les premières demandes de
remboursement ont été adressées aux
États membres de l'Union européenne à
compter du du mois de mai 2011 soit 1 an
après alors si les nouveaux règlements
ont permis de rééquilibrer un peu la
charge financière entre l'ancien état
d'emploi et l'État de résidence ce
déséquilibre persiste aujourd'hui en
faveur d'état-membres qui ont un nombre
important de travailleurs frontaliers
exerçant une activité dans un autre État
membre et vous connaissez bien monsieur
le sénateur de la Haute Savoie ce sujet
je veux donc vous préciser que conscient
du caractère non équilibré du système
actuel qui fait reposer sur l'État de
résidence la charge de l'indemnisation
la Commission a publié une déclaration
dans laquelle elle s'engage notamment à
lancer un processus de discussion sur le
chapitre chômage afin d'évaluer si un
réexamen des principe posés dans le
règlement est nécessaire c'est pourquoi
et c'est une perspective qui est devant
nous monsieur le sénateur ce réexamen
devrait aboutir à des propositions de
modification législative en 2014 dans
cette attente la France
parallèement se réserve la possibilité
de négocier d'autres méthodes de
remboursement plus favorables par voie
d'accord bilatéral et bien évidemment
vous en serez tenu informé merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole à
Monsieur Jean-Claude Carl pour répondre
à Monsieur le
Ministre le Président je remercie
monsieur le ministre des précisions
qu'il a bien voulu m'apporter sur un
dossier qu'il connaît bien aussi puisque
si la Savoie est moins concerné que la
hautre Savoie il y a aussi des
travailleurs frontaliers euh en euh en
savoix je crois qu'effectivement euh il
faut réparer cette injustice je prends
acte donc de la volonté du gouver
gouvernement de d'aller vers une
solution j'allais dire plus juste he et
plus équitable et qui pénalise moins à
la fois nos entreprises et nos salariés
qui côisent à l'Unedic alors peut-être
que ça passe par des modifications
législatives monsieur le ministre je
seraai très vigilant je sais que vous
aussi et je pense sans doute aussi à
votre collègue monsieur moskivici dont
le département est lui aussi très
concerné par ce problème frontalier donc
jeêmement vigilant au propos qui seront
faites